[Music]
here to teach me some self-defense
techniques using ordinary household
items this might save your life is our
good friend professional stuntman Steven
ho Steven we're gonna learn and the
break beforehand I saw you stretching
and limbering up and I have not done
that yet so you talk and I'll get limber
okay well in the past we've already
taught you some basic self-defense moves
yes remember your palm thrust you pocket
you [ __ ] you palm tree headbutt head
blows
wow that's for the groin we've done we
were in the groin a lot yes so we're
gonna now we're gonna work on ordinary
items for self-defense and how we can
how that can save your life one day okay
so these are things that might just be
lying around that you can use as weapons
could be in your purse could be in your
bathroom could be in your clarity I
don't carry a purse but all right here
we go so before we do that let's start
with just the basic reminder of a
nightstand so it's a nice thing what do
you mean well in any self-defense
situation or fighting situation you have
to be don't be caught heavy footed you
want to be light on your toes like a cat
right you're talking to the right guy
now
trying to like that not so dancer II
like what do you maybe what is that what
do you mean like way tell me what you
think just a little bit better for
posture this way so you can there you go
we're gonna talk about distance
okay so I'll draw a circle around you
yes and basically this circle is your
critical distance circle it could be
your your danger zone basically it's
your DMZ line okay so so anything this
is what and people should use this
anything that happens outside this zone
is not my concern
everyone circle is different you're a
big guy with the long reach so you have
a very big circle some people have
smaller circles okay so it really
depends and then anyone when anyone
enters this circle they've entered my
zone and I must attack exactly anything
out here is free when I come inside then
it's on now we're engaged okay well why
is it not affecting you in any way okay
you like me to iron so that's crazy okay
[Applause]
just letting the blood pool into my shoe
I'm ready now so this is a very
important strategy yes keep in the back
of your head we're gonna come back to
this but for now we're gonna go back and
just start talking through different
items okay so for example hairspray
everyone has the can of hairspray
somewhere I've got many cans yeah you
don't think much of it but if you do it
properly then obviously you could spray
it in someone's face okay and then you
can distract them in the stomach okay
you know or the groin that part of
rehearse okay a comb ordinary item very
simple everyone has a comb yeah what
they don't realize is that the teeth of
the comb are actually really really
sharp yeah and if you use it effectively
yeah just none of this is gonna hurt
yeah that's right yeah and you can go to
the neck right thank you
you could take it underneath to the
groin you see a pattern here Steven
that's self-defense
yeah I know but everything goes to the
groin eventually anyway you could use
this as effectively as a razor yeah if
you do it properly also a rock
pointing that out Sharpie pen sure to my
favorites
Oh so start a real mean about somebody
hurt their feelings
drop your pen it's legal it's small you
can carry in your pocket you can put in
your you know thing there hang on to it
but if you use it with the proper
technique you got you could actually go
right through something we broke that
Sharpie that's okay okay so you can
actually puncture through you know a lot
of skin yeah okay you can do that or
else you know that would really weren't
going to the glide right there and it's
really about your technique so you have
to go fast enough
yeah have enough all right so you be
like I'll mr. Brian I really love your
show love your autograph and they want
you comfortable you can go and just
[Applause]
despite what just happened I really
believe Sharpie does make the best pen
what you got there pal this is no gray
one just a cup of coffee okay could be
any sort of liquid but if you use it
properly especially something hot yeah
you wait until someone encroaches your
critical distance right but before yeah
then you could spit it in their face and
then you can follow up with take to the
garage to the guy so I've been doing
stuff on you would you like to try
something yeah okay on Ben okay okay
let's not you it's only fair I've been
hurting you
would you like to hurt Ben okay you come
at me
[Music]
[Applause]